♪ ♪
>> Chris: ON THIS FINAL
WEEKEND OF CAMPAIGNING,
JOE BIDEN LEFT HIS HOME BASE OF
DELAWARE FOR STOPS IN MUST-WIN
PENNSYLVANIA AND UPPER MIDWEST
SWING STATES.
JOINING US NOW FROM MINNEAPOLIS,
SENATOR AMY KLOBUCHAR, A KEY
SUPPORTER OF THE VICE PRESIDENT.
SENATOR, A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
SURPRISED ON FRIDAY TO SEE NOT
JUST PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN IN THE
STATE OF MINNESOTA, A STATE THAT
HASN’T VOTED FOR A REPUBLICAN
FOR PRESIDENT IN 11 STRAIGHT
ELECTIONS, SINCE RICHARD NIXON
BACK IN 1972, BUT THERE’S A
REASON.
LET’S LOOK AT THE LATEST REAL
CLEAR POLITICS AVERAGE OF RECENT
POLLS.
BIDEN LEADS THE PRESIDENT IN
MINNESOTA 48% TO 43.3%, PRETTY
CLOSE, SO THE QUESTION IS, ARE
MINNESOTA’S TEN ELECTORAL VOTES
IN PLAY?
>> Senator Klobuchar: I DON’T
BELIEVE THEY ARE AND I WAS SO
PLEASED THAT VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN STOPPED BY.
HE WAS IN WISCONSIN, HE WAS IN
IOWA, HE IS IN VIEW POINT OUT IN
PENNSYLVANIA TODAY.
HE’S ALL OVER THE MIDWEST.
AND SERIOUSLY, CHRIS, HE IS THE
HEAD OF MINNESOTA IN MANY OTHER
POLLS BY DOUBLE DIGITS.
HE’S AHEAD IN WISCONSIN, WHERE I
AM GOING TODAY, BRAVELY GOING AS
A VIKINGS FAN TO GREEN BAY TO
MEET UP WITH TAMMY BALDWIN, THE
SENATOR FROM WISCONSIN.
HE IS AHEAD IN SO MANY STATES IN
THE MIDWEST.
WHY?
ONE, HE IS LEADING WITH
MANUFACTURING AND A BIG WAY AND
BUYING AMERICA.
TWO, HE HAS BEEN WILLING TO TAKE
ON THE FACT THAT WE ARE NOT TO
GO SEPARATE COUNTRIES, THAT WE
MUST UNITE OUR NATION AND THAT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW IN
THE MIDWEST STRUGGLING BIG TIME
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS AND THE
LAST THING I ADD, SUBURBAN
VOTERS IN THE MIDWEST.
AFTER YOUR DEBATE THAT YOU
MODERATED WHERE HE INTERRUPTED
YOU OVER 100 TIMES, HE TOOK THE
STAGE AND SAID WHY DON’T
SUBURBAN WOMEN LIKE ME?
WELL, I CAN TELL YOU SOMEONE
THAT GREW UP IN THE SUBURBS,
THEY DON’T LIKE THE LACK OF
CIVILITY.
>> Chris: I ASKED COREY ABOUT
VOTER SUPPRESSION BUT I WANT TO
TAKE A LOOK AT A CASE IN
MINNESOTA WHERE TRADITIONALLY
VOTES HAVE TO BE IN, RECEIVED,
BY THE ELECTION BOARD BEFORE THE
END OF ELECTION NIGHT TO BE
COUNTED, BUT THE STATE THIS YEAR
MADE A CHANGE AND SAID THAT IF
VOTES ARE POSTMARKED BY ELECTION
DAY, THEY CAN COME IN AS MUCH AS
SEVEN DAYS LATER AND STILL BE
COUNTED, SO BY A TWO TO ONE
VOTE, A FEDERAL APPEALS COURT
SAID THOSE VOTES THAT DON’T COME
IN BY ELECTION DAY ARE GOING TO
BE SEPARATED AND KEPT SEPARATE
UNTIL A COURT CAN ROLL WHETHER
THEY SHOULD BE COUNTED OR NOT.
THAT’S A PRETTY DRAMATIC CHANGE
IN THE RULES.
ISN’T THAT A LEGITIMATE
CHALLENGE THE REPUBLICANS?
>> Senator Klobuchar: FIRST OF
ALL, CHRIS, THE REPUBLICANS AND
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ACTUALLY
AGREED TO [INDISCERNIBLE] SO
THEY COULD BE POSTMARKED BY THE
ELECTION BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
TWO ELECTORS WENT AROUND
REPUBLICAN ELECTORS AND WENT TO
THE COURTS.
WE REALLY ARE FOCUSED RIGHT NOW
ON MAKING SURE PEOPLE CAN VOTE
AND WE ARE JUST TELLING THEM
DON’T VOTE BY MAIL ANYMORE, TAKE
YOUR BALLOT TO A DROP OFF BOX.
WE’VE GOT PLENTY OF THEM IN
MINNESOTA, IT’S NOT LIKE TEXAS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE STILL VALIANTLY
PHONING THAT ONLY HAVE ONE PER
COUNTY.
AND THEN SHOW UP IN PERSON.
WE HAVE EARLY VOTING GOING ON
ALL DAY TODAY, TOMORROW,
ELECTION DAY, SO WE STILL FEEL
REALLY GOOD ABOUT THE VOTING IN
MINNESOTA.
WE ARE NUMBER ONE IN THE COUNTRY
NEARLY EVERY PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION VOTING, SO WE ARE
POSITIVE ABOUT IT AND IT IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF ATTEMPTS
WE ARE SEEING TO CUT PEOPLE OUT
FROM VOTING.
I THINK IT’S WRONG.
>> Chris: I WANT TO TALK TO
ABOUT SOME ISSUES.
IN THE FINAL PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE
JOE BIDEN SAID THAT HE WOULD --
THESE ARE HIS WORDS --
TRANSITION FROM THE OIL INDUSTRY
AND DURING THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY DEBATES, WHEN YOU WERE
RUNNING AGAINST JOE BIDEN,
DURING ONE OF THEM HE SAID HE
WOULD ELIMINATE FRACKING.
HE’S KIND OF TRIED TO PULL BACK
FROM BOTH OF THOSE STATEMENTS.
HERE’S WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
THIS WEEK ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
>> JOE BIDEN CONFIRMED HIS PLAN
TO ABOLISH THE ENTIRE U.S. OIL
INDUSTRY.
I SAID YOU MEAN NO MORE OIL,
JOE?
THAT’S WHAT I MEAN.
>> Chris: BIDEN SAYS HE WANTS
ZERO NET EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE
GASES BY 2050.
FACT IS, IF YOU’RE GOING TO
REALLY DO ALL THOSE THINGS THAT
HE’S TALKING ABOUT, IT’S GOING
TO HURT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
DEPEND ON FOSSIL FUELS FOR JOBS.
>> Senator Klobuchar: WELL,
LET ME CLARIFY THE FACTS, FIRST
OF ALL.
HE HAS MADE VERY CLEAR THAT HE
IS NOT AGAINST FRACKING, HE JUST
WANTS TO HAVE SAFETY RULES IN
PLACE AND NATURAL GAS --
>> Chris: NO NO.
I MEAN AGAIN -- SENATOR, LET ME
FACT-CHECK.
>> Senator Klobuchar: OKAY.
OKAY.
>> Chris: HE SAID HE WILL NOT
ALLOW ANY NEW FRACKING ON
FEDERAL LANDS.
>> Senator Klobuchar: OKAY,
THAT IS CORRECT.
WE ARE TALKING BUT EXISTING
FRACKING.
SECONDLY, WHAT HE’S TALKING
ABOUT IS STOPPING THESE OIL
SUBSIDIES AND TRANSITIONING TO
RENEWABLE FUELS TO BRING DOWN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
LOOK AT THE FIRES RAGING IN THE
WEST COAST, OUR MILITARY
PREDICTED THIS, CHRIS, THAT THIS
WOULD HAPPEN, AND THAT’S WHAT
HAPPENED THIS PAST FALL.
YOU LOOK AT ALL THE FLOODING WE
ARE SEEING, THE WEIRD WEATHER
EVENTS, THE INCREASE IN
HURRICANES, THE EFFECT THAT IT
HAS HAD ON THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
THEY ARE STILL COMING IN AND I
THINK THAT WHAT HE IS TALKING
ABOUT IS SHARED BY SCIENTISTS
AND BY ACTUALLY OUR OWN MILITARY
THAT WE NEED TO START TACKLING
THIS PROBLEM AND HE’S GOING TO
DO IT IN A SMART WAY THAT WILL
EVENTUALLY ADD MORE JOBS TO
AMERICA.
I THINK THAT’S WHAT’S IMPORTANT
BUT I DID WANT TO GET AT SOME
THE ECONOMIC ARGUMENTS THAT
COREY WAS MAKING IN HIS SEGMENT
BEFORE I WENT ON.
I THOUGHT IT WAS FASCINATING
FROM FOX.
SPIRIT I’VE GOT -- YOU KNOW --
THANK YOU.
>> Senator Klobuchar: YOU ARE
THE MODERATOR.
>> Chris: THANK YOU.
[LAUGHS]
THANK YOU!
I SOMETIMES FORGET THAT.
BEYOND THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE,
THE OTHER BIG ELECTION NEWS OF
COURSE IS THE RACE FOR CONTROL
OF THE SENATE.
THE CURRENT MARGIN 53-47, YOU
NEED A NET PICKUP OF 4 TO
CONTROL THE SENATE OR BIDEN WIN
AND PICK UP OF THREE THEN
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
WOULD BE ABLE TO BREAK THE TIE
VOTE.
YOU HAVE A CLOSE RACE.
YOU ARE NOT IN IT BUT A CLOSE
RACE IN MINNESOTA, PUT IT UP ON
THE SCREEN.
IT REAL CLEAR POLITICS RANKS THE
MINNESOTA RACE BETWEEN THE
INCUMBENT DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR TINA SMITH AND
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JASON
LEWIS AS A TOSS-UP.
QUICKLY, WHAT ARE THE CHANCES
THAT SMITH WILL WIN, HOLD ONTO
THAT SEAT, AND WHAT ARE THE
CHANCES THE DEMOCRATS WILL TAKE
OVER CONTROL OF THE SENATE?
>> Senator Klobuchar: SMITH
HOLDING ONTO A SEAT, I PUT IT
100%.
PAUL CAME OUT TODAY, SHE’S NINE
POINTS AHEAD.
SENATE RACES, WE ARE AHEAD IN
ARIZONA, WE ARE AHEAD IN
COLORADO.
WE ARE AHEAD IN THE NUMBER OF
POLLS IN MAINE.
WE ARE AHEAD -- THE HOLES GO
BACK AND FORTH.
IN NORTH CAROLINA WE ARE AHEAD.
WE ARE DOING WELL IN STATES LIKE
GEORGIA, SOUTH CAROLINA, ALASKA.
YOU NAME IT.
IF SO I AM FEELING GOOD ABOUT
THE SENATE.
I CAN’T GIVE YOU A PERCENTAGE ON
THAT.
BUT REMEMBER, I JUST WANT TO SAY
TO YOUR VIEWERS HERE, IF YOU ARE
SICK AND TIRED OF A PRESIDENT
THAT HAS NOT DONE WHAT HE HAS
SAID HE’S DONE, WHICH IS NOT
KEEP AMERICANS SAFE WHEN WE HAVE
CORONAVIRUS SPIKING, PICK A GUY
THAT’S GOT A PLAN, THAT’S
LISTENING TO THE SCIENCE, WHO’S
GOING TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
AND GET THE VACCINE OUT IN A WAY
THAT MAKES SENSE.
THIS IS REALLY THE HEART AND
SOUL OF THE ARGUMENT HERE AT THE
END.
>> Chris: FINALLY, SENATOR, AS
YOU SAID, I’M THE MODERATOR OR
IN THIS CASE THE HOST.
SENATOR, JOE BIDEN AND YOU RAN
IN THE CENTRIST LANES DURING THE
PRIMARIES, BUT IT’S BEEN
INTERESTING WATCHING WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS SAYING SHE
WOULD LIKE TO BE SECRETARY OF
THE TREASURY.
BERNIE SANDERS HAS TALKED ABOUT
PUSHING FOR SECRETARY OF LABOR.
KAMALA HARRIS, WHO WOULD BE
VICE PRESIDENT, IS RATED THE
MOST LIBERAL MEMBER OF THE
SENATE.
IF JOE BIDEN WINS, ISN’T THE
LEFT GOING TO COME AFTER HIM
REALLY HARD AFTER THE ELECTION?
>> Senator Klobuchar: CHRIS,
RIGHT NOW JOE BIDEN IS FOCUSED
ON UNITING THIS COUNTRY AND OUR
PARTY HAD STAYED UNITED, BUT
WHAT I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO REALIZE, HE HAS BROUGHT AND
PEOPLE LIKE JOHN KASICH, FORMER
GOVERNOR, REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF
OHIO.
CINDY McCAIN --
>> Chris: BUT HE’S NOT GOING
TO BE IN THE CABINET.
I’M TALKING ABOUT
ELIZABETH WARREN AS TREASURY
SECRETARY OR BERNIE SANDERS AS
LABOR SECRETARY.
>> Senator Klobuchar: I HAVE
NO IDEA WHO HE’S GOING TO PICK
FOR THE CABINET.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THE WAY HE HAS
RUN HIS CAMPAIGN, THE WAY HE HAS
SAID HE’S GOING TO BE THE
PRESIDENT NOT JUST FOR THE
PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR HIM BUT THE
PEOPLE THAT VOTE AGAINST HIM.
THAT’S HOW HE’S GOING TO GOVERN.
HE HAS GOT SO MUCH TO DO IN
THOSE FIRST 100 DAYS AND I JUST
THINK THAT THIS ELECTION, IF IT
GOES DOWN THE WAY WE ARE SEEING
WITH HIM AHEAD IN PLACES LIKE
GEORGIA AND SOME POLLS IN TEXAS,
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE COUNTRY
SAYING "ENOUGH OF THE DIVIDE.
ENOUGH OF THE FIGHTING.
WE WANT TO GO TOGETHER AS A
TEAM.
TEAM AMERICA AND MOVE FORWARD
AND WIN THIS THING FOR OUR
COUNTRY" AND THAT MEANS TAKING
ON THIS VIRUS, SHUTTING DOWN A
VIRUS, AND OPENING UP OUR
ECONOMY.
THAT’S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.